مدارس خلت من ضجيج التلاميذ وحركهم ساحه
هادئه وفصول مغلقه بعد ان رفع المعلمون
شعار تحسين الاجر مقابل العمل
اضراب كان متدرجا ومتدبدبا لكنه دخل الان
الى مرحله جديده بعد ان طلبت بعض المدارس
من تلاميذها عدم الحضور الى المدرسه بسبب
الاضراب
المطالبه بزياده الراتب مئه وخمسه عشر
دولارا كلها اسباب واعذار لم تجد طريقها
الى الحل
هم بطالبه
بالصرف على التعليم باعتبار النهائيه قضيه
بتم المجتمع بشكل عام انه لابد للدوله ان
تضع ميزانيه 20% من موازنتها للصرف على
التعليم
والمعلمين بيطالبه برده بزياده الحد
الادنى
69% من الحد الادنى
للازمه هنا بعد اخر
المتضررون هم تلاميذ المدارس الحكوميه اثر
خلاف ضل قائما بين المعلمين ووزاره
التربيه والتعليم بسبب ضعف المرتبات كارثه
تنذر بان يخسر التلاميذ عامهم الدراسي
ترسلون نجلاء ابنتها ترتيل الى المدرسه
يوميا دون فائده تذكر اذ اصبحت الام تؤدي
دور المدرسه في التعليم استياء كان واضحا
على اسر عديده يدرس ابنائهم في المدارس
الحكوميه نحن
الاضراب بتاع المعلمين ده فين الطالب يعني
العام الدراسي
في مدارس مضربه مدارس غير مطربه يعني حتى
في الحكومي ذاته
تداعيات استدعت ان تتدخل وزاره التربيه
والتعليم لتعلن عن تعديل التقويم الدراسي
بمنح اجازه تبدا في الحادي عشر من هذا
الشهر وتستمر ثلاثه اسابيع
معالجات يراها البعض تطويل الازمه وهروب
من الحل
فالدراسه في السودان باتت تتعطل للاضراب
والتظاهرات والخريف وبعض الامراض وايضا في
منح الاجازات لن يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم